Welcome back everyone Spider-Man Across The
Spider-Verse part one was just released and we
need to talk about the ending of the movie is very
similar to the way they ended Avengers Infinity
War the movie was conceived the same way Avengers
Infinity war and Avengers end game were developed
being part one of a two-part movie basically if
you're new to the channel be sure to subscribe
to get all the videos we're doing a giveaway for
tickets to the movie all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and post your favorite moments
from the movie in the comments and careful for
spoilers if you haven't seen the movie yet at the
end of the movie Miles Morales escapes Spider-Man
2099's spider-society base in his Universe using
the Advanced Technologies created basically like
a giant Master Weaver mechanical spider that
manipulates the spider-verse layer of reality
to send different Multiverse characters they
capture back to their original universes it's
sort of like a giant mechanical version
of a madame web type of creature operated
by a spider bite here the reason Spider-Man
2099 sets every single version of Spider-Man
after Miles Morales was because Miles Morales is
supposed to be the original Multiverse accident
that wasn't supposed to happen that threatens
all of reality according to Spider-Man 2099 he
believes miles threatens all of reality during
the movie The Spider force of different versions
of Spider-Man he puts together are dedicated to
stopping tears in the Multiverse from destroying
universes basically like a version of the TVA
but make it Spider-Man stopping different Nexus
events in different universes from destroying
all of reality so the plot is very similar to
what's happening with Avengers 5 Kang Dynasty
in Avengers 6 secret words they're just using
slightly different terms to describe it there's a
lot of moments during the movie that also connect
with the live-action Spider-Man movies too lots
of cameos of course I'll discuss those in my full
breakdown in Easter eggs video because there's
so much happening like pretty much every Theory
you had about this movie wound up being correct in
some way but you can think of all these accidents
in the movie that happen in different universes
like the incursions in the MCU during the movie
they explained that the number 42 spider that
bit Miles Morales giving him his origin as a
version of Spider-Man was from Another Universe
verse Universe 42 like Earth 42 Miles Morales is
from the Ultimate Universe Earth 1610 the spot the
real villain of the movie was a scientist working
on kingpin's Super collider during the events
of the first movie he brought that spider from
Earth 42 to miles's Universe Spider-Man 2099
claims that Miles Morales was never supposed
to become Spider-Man in that accident caused the
death of his Universe version of Peter Parker and
everything that's happening with the incursions
all over the Multiverse in the movie threatening
all of reality is miles's fault because if he
hadn't become Spider-Man his Peter Parker would
have lived and been able to stop Kingpin super
collider before it was able to explode causing
that initial accident that set everything off
Miles Morales and the other versions of Spider-Man
in the movie who take his side in all this like
spider Gwen spider bite Hobie brown spider Punk
Peter B Parker all help him escape the base he
thinks the Master spider Weaver is sending him
back to his universe but what's really happening
is that device is detecting the DNA from that
spider that bit him and instead winds up sending
him back to the spiders original Universe Earth
42 in that Universe the color palette is way
darker everything with the whole tone the vibe
of everything is way darker just because it's
meant to be a universe where things went very
badly because of what happened because the spider
that was supposed to turn someone into Spider-Man
in this universe like this universe version of
Miles Morales didn't wind up biting this Miles
because it came to another universe and bit the
other miles and what wound up happening is that
Earth 42 version of Miles Morales goes dark
and becomes a version of the prowler taking
the mantle from his uncle Aaron Davis and in that
Universe miles's father is the one who's killed in
the line of duty because there is no Spider-Man to
stop a lot of the criminals he sees a mural in the
place where he drew one for his uncle Aaron like
oh no it was my father that was the one that died
in this universe so on Earth 42 Aaron Davis wind
up Surviving and teaching that Universe version of
Miles Morales all the wrong lessons and he goes
dark becoming the proud when they discover the
truth that Aaron Davis captures and straps miles
to a punching bag it's meant to be a parallel to
the first movie when Miles Morales did the same
thing to Peter B Parker when they first met
get electric handed me with his handstands
when miles realizes what's happening like oh
I'm tied up and this is an alternate Earth and
this version of Aaron Davis isn't my real Uncle
it's the other miles's Uncle because his skills
have gotten so much better and because of what
happened in that original scene in the first
movie with Peter B Parker easily escaping his
trap tied to the bag they might have a similar
scene with this version of Miles Morales now
much better at being Spider-Man with his powers
escaping the same type of way here's lesson number
one kid don't watch the mouth watch the hand yes
only this time they want miles to feel even worse
like he's somehow responsible for this universe
going down the tubes because he stole Spider-Man
from this Earth somehow even though technically
it's not his fault like the spot is the person
who brought the spider from this universe blame
the spot for everything that's going bad in the
movie they and his part of the story in the movie
with a scene of him discovering his Earth 42 self
as the prowler who makes it seem like he's going
to kill miles as revenge for the death of his
father in this universe like how dare you take
this for me take my father from me even though
like I said it's not miles's fault like miles
is trying to win over this alternate version of
himself and Aaron Davis like you have to free me
because I have to stop the spot because the spot
is threatening all of reality in the movie The
Spot is kind of like a version of the beyonders
during Secret Wars he wants to basically erase the
entire Multiverse and remake it in his own image
while this is going on with Miles spider Gwen also
escapes the spider Society base with Hobie brown
spider Punk's self gives her a homemade cobbled
together webwear wristwatch allowing her to open
portals across the Multiverse which she uses to go
to Miles Morales real Universe tell his parents
some of what happened not everything like she
doesn't outright tell them that he's a version
of Spider-Man and about what's happening with
the spot in the spider war with the spider Society
miles does try to tell his mother the truth about
him being a version of Spider-Man but it was the
earth 42 version of his mother and while he's
discovering that he came to the wrong Earth so I
think that eventually in the third movie he will
tell his parents the truth like I am a version
of Spider-Man Gwen then uses her wrist device
to collect her own side team of Spider-Man made
up of their team from the first movie in addition
to MayDay Parker who's still with Peter B Parker
in Spider-Man India Penny Parker Spider-Man Noir
spider ham all come back from the first movie
and spider Gwen takes them to Earth 42 to rescue
Miles Morales while this is also happening the
spot who at this point is consumed enough dark
energy from different Universe versions of the
super collider giving him the power of great
to affect reality in a much bigger scale travels
to miles morales's original Universe claiming
earlier that he was going to take everything from
miles and they want you to think because of the
longer Uncle Ben death Montage early in the movie
the captain Stacy death Montage where there's
this big talk about how they're always supposed
to die in every Universe giving each version of
Spider-Man their tragic origin story they want
you to think that because in miles's Universe
his father just became captain of the police
this means the spot will kill him also earlier
in the movie his father has all these lines of
dialogue where he keeps saying that he'll never
leave them he'll always be here to help miles
the kind of foreshadowing you would normally
give a character that you plan on killing off but
a big plot point in the movie is that because of
miles's unique accident that made him Spider-Man
he can change the Canon like the way that things
are supposed to happen and it won't destroy all of
reality like him changing the story won't create
Nexus events because spider Gwen essentially does
the same thing in her Universe her father Captain
Stacy quits his job as Captain he isn't killed
off like was supposed to happen according to
Spider-Man 2099 and her universe is totally fine
like oh you can change things and it will be okay
meaning that Spider-Man 2099 was wrong about some
things not everything but he's wrong about Miles
Morales being a mistake and they end the movie
with Gwen running into the portal to Earth 42
and the message just reads to be continue dot dot
dot in the title teaser for Spider-Man beyond the
spider-verse which is part two of across the
spider verse sort of like their Empire Strikes
Back Avengers Infinity War part 1 Downer ending
where you know the story is going to pick up with
a year almost immediately where they left off
right now beyond the spider verse is supposed
to come out next year I don't know if they're
going to delay it or if they're going to be
any changes to that the hard out ending is going
to surprise some people there are no actual real
post-credits scenes or mid-credit scenes like this
is the closest we get to a post credit scene is
this beyond the spider-verse teaser normally we'd
have to wait like four years before the next movie
came out during that the spot will become a much
more Central villain the story with spider Gwen's
smaller teen trying to stop him eventually they'll
probably win over Spider-Man 2099 who will come
around on Miles and the rest of the spider force
with all the different versions of Spider-Man will
help them out there's also reports that we'll
see some of the spider-verse characters cross
over in live action during Avengers 6 secret
words we'll see about that but they also just
announced that they're developing a live-action
Miles Morales Spider-Man movie and a spider Gwen
spin-off movie with hailee Steinfeld cannot wait
to see the actors try to talk their way around
answering questions about showing up as multiple
versions of live-action characters and stuff like
Avengers Secret Wars that'll be crazy who do you
think wins it's not stupid I've thought about it
um who do I think actually wins wow you know
Kate will be more experienced you think Gwen
really yeah I think so too you could just feel
hailee Steinfeld trying to answer and not answer
at the same time that is an art form that you
learn over time that's why they paired Benedict
Cumberbatch with Tom Holland and all their
Infinity War interviews just to prevent Tom
Holland from giving away spoilers I'll talk more
about those later tonight in my Spider-Man 4 Tom
Holland video because they also just announced a
bunch of details and news about that that video
will be up in a couple hours my full breakdown in
Easter eggs for across the spider-verse will post
on Friday I have to watch the movie like five more
times to catch them all there's so many details in
Cameo scenes in every single scene be sure to
enable alerts for my channel so you don't miss
those everyone click here for that Spider-Man 4
video and click here for my Spider-Man across the
spider-verse full breakdown and Easter eggs video
I'll update the links as soon as I post those
videos thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!